welcome to you heard with purd I'm purd
hapley the story of our guest today is
that they are from the Department of
Parks and Recreation Ben Wyatt and Tom
Haverford what up heard big fan
me too purd what up the thing about this
first question is I'd like to ask you
about the Harvest Festival bird it's
going to be amazing carnival rides games
Sweden is even building a plus size
roller coaster for some of pawnee's
obese Thrill Seekers you must be this
wide to ride wow that's going to be a
pretty big roller coaster yep
hey guys how'd it go well there were
some sticky moments let's go to the
videotape
ah look who hasn't had Gay Thoughts who
you okay yeah I'm fine I'm fine I mean
you know sometimes I feel like I might
need glasses is there a bird in here I
swear I keep seeing a bird in the studio
maybe that's how this happens to it he
was fine until bird started asking about
the boy mayor's stuff what's wrong with
you you look psychotic I was eight
excuse me for that Cindy Eckert had just
turned me down for senior prom do you
know how that feels I should call her I
should no I shouldn't and I'm not going
to and I'm proud of myself
and then he talked about filling up
Cindy Eggert for the first time for
about five minutes and then the show
ended as did our careers and probably
harvest fest
boom sadness that's the one
hello and welcome to Pawnee today I'm
Joan calamezzo today's guest is Leslie
Knope who is here to tell us how this
year's Harvest Festival is going to
bankrupt the city
well Joan actually there's a lot of
false information flying around the
Harvest Festival is jumping right in
it's rude I just want everyone to know
what an extraordinary event this is
going to be but at what cost
many cities does Ben Wyatt need to
destroy before he's put behind bars Ben
Wyatt has done nothing wrong
you know
if you want to ask him questions let's
go for it huh let's ask any question
about his past or present just get it
over with Ben let's get up here yeah
yeah come on
yeah we'll just ask him a bunch of
questions and then we'll get everything
cleared and out of the way sound good
yeah great good uh let's take some calls
John why don't you okay uh call her are
you there
yeah how can you justify raising taxes
for something that will hurt the town
I
for the
just to add to what Ben's stammering
about um we aren't going to raise taxes
so that's that next caller yeah why
should we trust this Ben Wyatt guy
because I'm trusty trust me I'm
trustworthy and I am working very hard
to
make sure that this town gets back on
its feet there we go
great next caller so I looked you up on
Alta Vista and I found out that the last
okay first of all why does everyone in
this town use Alta Vista is it 1997 and
second I am a budget specialist I went
to those towns because they were
bankrupt and now they aren't
and yeah I screwed up when I was 18 but
who doesn't do dumb stuff when they're
18.
Joan
stole my gym teacher's husband
so there you go
well what else you got callers going
once going to oh here we go
yeah hi um can you tell me more about
the corn maze at the Harvest Festival
are dogs allowed if I thought you were
serious I'd be offended bird but I know
that we're buddies and I know you
wouldn't do that to me but no this is a
birthmark purd okay this is the little
scar I got when I was nine and I fell
off my bike so no I'm not perfect I
can't look away it's a it's amazing okay
wait no here's the best part okay uh
that's all the time we have here on you
heard I'm heard happily channel four
more like turd crappley
yeah
oh
one